[Music]
there's this clip from Good Morning
America that's also making the rounds on
the internet and it shows anchor
Elizabeth Vargas asking some celebrities
what a certain word means during an
interview take a look a gentleman had
removed his briefs she was on stage
lying flat and he was about to teabag
her are you Seri I'm mad at you packing
I'm not gonna explain it sir
very hard to believe Elizabeth Vargas
didn't know about tea bagging everyone
knows what tea bagging is auntie yeah
sure tea bagging what do you not know of
course I do I know what it means I don't
think you know I don't think you know
Andy doesn't know what tea bagging is
[Laughter]
what the hell is teabagging probably has
to do with sports or something Wow
teabagging is everywhere
[Music]
maybe there is no teabagging
[Music]
oh that's what that is okay
[Music]
I understand because see my grandpa was
called that apple dump okay
I want to thank our studio audience for
waiting three months really for that to
play out nice very bleep the mouse beer
eyes they slept here